search teams looking for missing soldier
at Fort Hood Texas have found human
remains as they investigate her
disappearance private first class
Vanessa Guillen vanished more than two
months ago the unidentified human
remains were found about 30 miles from
the army base her family suspects that
her disappearance
is tied to alleged sexual harassment
Mireya Villarreal is covering this story
for us Maria this could be the news of
family does not want to hear when will
we know if Vanessa Guillen has been
found so we'll hopefully get those
answers in the next 24 to 48 hours from
forensic experts you know the family
attorney tells me that they are still
holding out hope but they are slowly
coming to grips with the reality that
this could be the body of Vanessa
Guillen now investigators were out at a
field yesterday afternoon in a community
called Little River Academy the remains
were found in a shallow grave
Vanessa Guillen was last seen April 22nd
and her family believes that her
disappearance is directly connected to
her claims that she was being sexually
harassed by someone on base he had never
filed a report with the army but
investigators were looking into those
claims as a part of this investigation
the director of a volunteer search
groups poked out yesterday about this
discovery I told the family I said that
there's no words
or anything I can do it this time no
words or anything anybody can do it this
time take your pain away the family is
in Washington DC today they plan to
protest this investigation they want a
congressional investigation to oversee
what exactly happened in this
disappearance what happened with the
sexual harassment claims and they want a
broader investigation into the issues on
Fort Hood space Anthony yeah so many
unanswered questions Maria we hope we
the family can find out what happened
thanks very much